this is an upside down crazy year with
training camp different and pre-season
difference so our draft today the random
things we miss about the old school
pre-2020 training camp shereen has a
trivia question for me that will
determine the first pick it will and
there's not a lot we missed but we do
miss some things so mike your trivia
question for the first pick is where did
the vikings hold their first training
camp
their first training camp their first
training this i feel
i feel like this is a trick question
because they were at mankato state
university for all those years but now i
have a feeling that that they were
somewhere else for their first training
camp so uh 61. 65.
oh 61 so it wasn't mankato state
university uh
i i have no idea i pass
all right um we'll see if i if
well yeah we'll see if i pronounce this
right is
bemidji
state college
bemidji bemidji bemidji okay bemidji
bemidji is it as a bonus do you know
what their mascot is
uh the the blue ox
they're the beavers and trent balkey the
49ers foreign
general manager is a alum of the school
maybe the most famous alum of the school
6 000 students they have so there you go
there's your trivia question of the day
the only reason i knew how to pronounce
pronounced bemidji is because that town
is the basis for one of the seasons of
fargo uh that's otherwise i would have
had no idea so um all right well you get
the first pick yeah that was a really
easy question thank you matt casey for
that one uh all right shereen you're up
all right i'm gonna go with with with
the fans interacting with the players
that's what i love most about it and i i
took one trip when i was a kid i was a
teenager and got to go to thousand oaks
and and get autographs for the players
and and watch the cowboys
train and it was a really big deal to me
and you know the price of tickets now is
outrageous in what it costs to go to
games and a lot of people can't afford
to go to games but they can't afford to
go to training camp to take their kids
out there take the whole family out
there it's free to get in that may cost
you concessions it may cost you parking
but it's minimal compared to what you'll
play for pay for a game to get in
and they get autographs from the players
and i love it when players stay around
and and sign autographs and you know i
would wait after games i remember after
a preseason game i waited for o.j
simpson gave up getting cowboy
signatures to go try to get o.j simpson
and sure enough i'm the only one there
and he grabs my pen
and never signs my program and gets on
the bus with my pen so i lost my pin and
didn't get an autograph from o.j simpson
but i do love those interactions that
fans have with players and they only get
that in training camp you know it would
it be a i'm not going to say it i'll
save it for a break uh of all the things
that o.j simpson could do to you
stealing your pen is probably the least
to be concerned about all right i said
it
next
next i'm sorry i'm sorry why should i
apologize he did it according to a civil
jury okay next up uh one thing i miss
and there's a fan component to it
especially when the cowboys and the rams
or was the cowboys and the raiders got
together not that long ago the fights
the fights the footage of the fights
especially when you have two teams
coming together it gets chippy it gets
nasty and they were up against that
fence out in california a couple of
years ago and it got a little it gets a
little concerning but the the fights and
the footage of the fights and the
discussion of the fights that i i miss
that even though it shouldn't happen
even though it's stupid even though you
may get guys injured for no reason
whatsoever it's it's one of the things
that uh makes training camp interesting
when guys blow their stack and uh beat
on each other
yeah that's the only time they can do
that right there's no penalties for it
and all that's gonna happen is the
training camp practice is gonna be cut
short hey all the more reason to fight
right
to get those practices cut off all right
mike for my second pick i'm gonna go
with hazing i do miss the hazing and and
some of it is is not good you know i
remember eric curry tying up a player to
a goal post and and doing some other
things to them that that i won't repeat
on here that that were not nice and uh
but but there are some fun kind of
hazing that that players do i remember
you know bill parcells used to always
have the players the the rookie the
first round draft pick would have to
bring him water every day during
practice that was terence newman we see
the players carrying shoulder pads back
of the veterans the rookies have to do
that dez bryant one year refused to do
that and didn't make many friends doing
that and you know tony dungy came into
tampa and he said we're not going to
have any hazing uh going on and really
cut that out but some of it to me is fun
it's in good natured and it sort of
teaches the rookies i guess their place
in the nfl welcome to the nfl rookie
yeah chris sims got it from warren sapp
in tampa back when chris was drafted
2003 that sapp was the guy i think chris
had to have his dip his tobacco ready
for him at any given moment that was
chris's chore in his early days with the
tampa bay buccaneers um i i i think of
the haircuts i think what they did to
tim tebow in 2010 in denver when it was
kind of like that friar tuck thing and
just the crazy hairdos and and they did
scale back on the hazing because they
can cross the line but some of it is
just flat out funny and it's part of
team building and camaraderie and
whatnot all right uh what else do i miss
i had a i had more on my list and now i
lost my list um
i i i miss
but i don't miss
but i do miss that vague and it's coming
when they put the pads on
but there's that that sense
every day
that you never know who's gonna tear an
acl you never know who's going to get
injured right there's just this nagging
constant worry of is that guy on my
fantasy team is that guy on the team i
like is that guy you know who is it
going to happen to because you know
what's going to happen it's this random
arbitrary lightning bolt and we don't
have that we won't have it until the
middle of august but usually that's
right away like within the first few
days you are bracing and i i hate to say
i miss it but it is that weird kind of
feeling of being on edge that something
bad is going to happen because you know
what's going to happen with all those
players and all those camps you know
it's going to happen it's not a good
thing but just that i and i guess i
should say i don't miss that feeling but
it is a weird feeling in early august to
not have that sense every day
that uh that there's going to be an
injury that shuts down a guy's season
you know instead we're bracing to see
who test positive for covet 19.
you're mr negativity mike can't you look
on the positive side and say i i miss
kyler murray and and seeing all those
rookies who are going to stand out and
be on my fantasy team and instead you
take the negative term but am i wrong
but no but am i wrong don't you i mean
don't players
right but but that's usually the first
two weeks of camp you have to walk
especially in this business you're
constantly wondering who's it gonna
happen to and that feeling isn't there
this year it's a different feeling it's
a weird feeling but that feeling of that
and it's coming when they put the pads
on on john gruden's birthday that's when
we'll have that feeling again all right
what else do you have shereen all right
i'm gonna go number three i'm gonna make
this all about me and and it's my trip
to oxnard california every year and and
you know the temperature in texas is
over 100 degrees usually in august we've
been very fortunate this august but i i
usually get to go to training camp and
get out of this heat for for multiple
weeks
have some fresh fish and fresh
strawberries and and get to watch some
preseason football and get to know the
players and i really miss that in those
up close
interactions that you get with players
as much as anything that's really when
you learn about players and you see some
of the guys who were you know 80th
on the 80th man or 90th man as it were
before this season coming in and being
able to make some rosters as an
undrafted free agent we've seen it so
many times and and i just don't think
those guys are going to get the chance
but uh to me it's just getting to
california getting that that trip to
california and get to see the guys uh
early in their careers in some cases as
undrafted free agents
have you ever had a drink at the rudder
room bar
oh yeah absolutely that's peter's place
peter king i that's i i'm not i was just
told to ask you that question i didn't
know that was a thing or a place until i
was told to ask you that all right uh
last one for me
we talked about this during the break
matt casey gave it away with kind of a
wild guess and kind of sarcastic but
it's true i miss hearing how everyone is
in the best shape of their life that's
always topic a
every guy reports in the best shape of
his life and he's ready to have the
biggest season of his career we're
getting a little bit of that
over-the-top delusion but i think
everybody's so distracted with the
pandemic that we've yet to get that
stream of guys declaring what great
shape they're in and the reality may be
they know they're not in the best shape
of their life because this year they
haven't been able to get and stay in the
best shape of their life
that's one of the reasons why well
that's true uh but uh everyone else is
still working to get in the best shape
of their life and then by the middle of
august when it's time to put the pads on
they can say they are now finally in the
best shape of their life all right let's
uh take a break the 49ers may have a
reason to be concerned it has nothing to
do with jimmy garoppolo it has nothing
to do with any other team in their
division but there is cause for
long-term worry if you're a 49ers fan
we'll discuss that next year on pft live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports